defending
I love you we are live though how are
you hello
I'm pretty good I'm here at the con in
Vegas
yeah so guys welcome to Sidetrack your
first time on here and we're talking
stuff with your make Mark who's going to
be defended
the new Star Trek I I might mention your
Star Trek a little bit oh you
I was not tall enough anyway your
startup was to be fair to my favorite
Star Trek episode of any Star Trek
episode ever was one of your Star Treks
regenerations I just love that and it's
got bacula is probably my favorite
Captain
well he's just underrated and like yeah
Captain Archer yeah
let's go
we couldn't have had a better guy at the
top of the food chain he was just uh he
made those years glorious and not
everyone in Hollywood does that when
they are top of the food chain so yeah
God bless him no I've seen him in a few
interviews he comes across like he does
on the on the show to be honest so
as well so that's obviously a bonus as
well yeah yeah working with Jolene yeah
yeah
she was all right
what do you guys doing for the rest of
the day then when you're uh we're gonna
be sitting and signing obviously it's uh
assigning events here in the daytime
um and then later on tonight we're going
for a very lovely dinner there's a high
roller Fanboy that takes us out to a
couple of dinners here yep lesson Dave
tab thanks Dave uh and we'll be at
Hell's Kitchen tonight for uh the chef's
table at Gordon Ramsay's restaurant
it's not bad I have to say God bless
this job and uh God bless all you fans
out there and uh yeah it's lovely coming
here with my mate and uh and now we've
got a shuttle pod show presence here
we're really excited this is our first
year uh sort of you know uh bringing the
show to the to the con yeah and I think
um by this time next year we're going to
be quite a presence here
um the show's really taking off it is
yeah we need all you guys out there and
I'm the guy banging the drum we love
that you chime in and come and support
and watch and all that what we need now
is for you all to become little patreon
members and help support this show
financially okay we're just at the
Tipping Point uh but it's got to start
paying for itself and we're very close
so please if you can find that five
dollars in your pocketbook uh we really
need that and it's a it's a donation
it's not a it's not for the mugs it's
not for the t-shirts though you will get
that but we just need your support
financially you know we like this time
we like the t-shirts and you can have
them
um but don't think of it in those terms
[Laughter]
you should be on my side you're British
well
um 30 years in America now man so you
know I go both ways
yeah
but uh no thank you so much then and
yeah um
I'm gonna let Connor sit down uh it's
gonna be an interesting battle uh I
actually just have been watching a bit
of the new strange new worlds and I I I
like it I gotta say I wasn't sure that I
was gonna like it but I watched the uh
the lower decks episode when they
brought the two um
yeah a bit camp and uh some good humor
and uh no they all they all they all
fill out very well it looks like they've
obviously you know production values
there's so much better these days and
for less money as it were or the same
money
it looks fantastic they spend like six
or seven million quid an episode
apparently do they are well they're
doubling our budget then uh it shows on
the screen it looks bloody good so
listen I'm gonna let Connor sit down and
say hello to you real quick yeah uh good
luck again tomorrow because he's a tough
competitor let me tell you yeah yeah
you're gonna have your work cut out all
right buddy thank you so much thanks
Malcolm
foreign
trip you're dead
well I'm sort of dead
sort of yeah that episode didn't really
happen so I think we're okay hey I'm
just mostly dead yeah
thank you so much for sitting down and
yeah man pleasure
um my internet started going crazy the
lovely blue screen but
um how are you find in Vegas
oh I've done this I've done this many
many many years uh um it's always great
it feels this year different in the
sense that
we kind of we've gone back to
pre-pandemic uh energy uh so that's nice
I was going to say like last year must
have felt weird because that's always
last year would have been the first year
sort of properly back no the year that
was really weird was when we had to have
the plexiglass screens in front of us
and split between our photo ops and that
kind of stuff but
um last year was in a different location
and we're it's nice to be back in Korea
yeah how is the sort of everything going
on in Hollywood affecting things though
do you I mean because obviously the
strikes and everything else does it make
it more complicated or are you just
actually you're there for the fans
anyway so does it really matter
it does complicate it a bit because
um
we're not allowed to really talk about
the show that we might or might not have
been on
um
yeah um you know look hey
we've got a lot to fight for here
um and uh it seems to be a watershed
moment we're sitting here at the Rubicon
and
um I think that we need to won the
writers and the actors need to get
together and
um
you know find a way for us to all make a
a fair living yeah
yeah we keep telling people on this
channel it's not about the five percent
of actors and writers that you know
their name it's about the 95 of actors
that you might not know their names and
that bring us all this amazing
entertainment and it's the future of
Hollywood we're fighting for and look
we're we're all fighting for a middle
class life
that's what we're doing
yeah
yeah you should be able to live quickly
like some people say that they're just
actors and things like no these people
it's like entertainment in media that's
the that's the first thing that goes
and sometimes you know in Manchester
United struggle and we should fight for
it well you know what do fascists do
they control the art
and yeah and we want a free
well yeah I want you guys to do what you
do we want to be able to live and do
what we do and uh support our families
and that's it
yeah well that's all that's all any of
us want really isn't it yeah exactly
looking for kids and
something you love
so have you been watching strange new
worlds because I know Dominic said he's
been watching a bit I haven't seen it
yet I haven't seen it yet in fact I have
not seen a lot of new track
um and oddly I'm I'm here to pull you
out into the ring
I'm getting a reputation of something
that doesn't like new track and I'm not
I love it I just have been honest about
the bits I don't like
listen I I've heard I've heard those
arguments as well and um
you know I do think from what I've heard
strange new worlds
finds a balance between uh the new and
the uh Legacy
it's very much like if that's what it
feels like but it's it's amazing but I
kind of thank you so much for sitting
down with us just for two minutes and
um enjoy Vegas not too much thanks man
nice to see you well should I introduce
this
well all right let's get ready to rumble
he's going down we've got old Trek
versus Legacy Trek versus new track
gentlemen put your gloves on be very
kind to each other but kick each other's
ass
thank you Connor
are these ours yes
one for me is it like a regular cup
Maybe
did he get his did Dominic get his hi hi
Mark how you doing sir I'm excellent how
are you I'm very very well and did I
hear you ordering three whiskeys
like 10 A.M
I don't blame you I'm not even drinking
yeah
is that yours
sorry it's a proud hit um that's yours
Tom
hide it hide it
yes thank you gentlemen
sorry uh it's uh it's a little hectic
here there's a lot of people here
that's amazing I mean I haven't been to
Vegas Comic Con so it's just amazing to
see this
uh it's gonna feel like I should wave at
people
anyway we're having a good time me next
year honestly if if these two of Comic
Cons in San Diego Comic-Con are this
close together again next year yeah I'm
going I'm doing it that's our plan
Sidetrack will be at
that
um so you talked up uh Connor and
Dominic I told them that you were
challenging me to defend new uh new Trek
which is something I'm very very happy
to do excellent and let's get into it
but first of all have you seen the
musical episode yes I watched it this
morning in fact and thoughts
um I was on the verge of tears by the
time the episode was done because uh I
love musicals and I love Star Trek and
everything about it
for me was fun I wish there were more
start I'm shocked it took so long to
have a Star Trek musical well
apparently picardony did it and I I
really can't see how that would have
worked
well they're the same uh filmmakers who
make stranger worlds in Picard so that
makes sense truly though I don't see how
it would have worked but
yeah I agree maybe all of season two
should have been a musical then uh the
the light plot would have been
um more fun
you know
well I've put together a couple of
little statements that go to what I've
had a problem with Star Trek for a
little while and we're just going to
discuss them but I've been purposefully
a little bit confrontational on the way
I've written them so please don't blame
me if they're written like this on
purpose I'm already getting a lot of
crap for being a Star Trek hater and I'm
not I'm a bloody Trekkie
um oh I made sure to tell Connor and
Dominic that you don't hate Star Trek
I love stuff like it's mine I was like
he loves it
um but like everything that we love
sometimes
you know you get a little disappointed
but yeah the strange news world to
musical was not really Star Trek and
would have been better apparently as a
Christmas special or something along
those lines
um I honestly believe my only real
problem with the musical is that it's
episode nine of a 10 season 10 episode
run I see if it had been like a
Christmas special or a surprise 11th
episode I'd have been happy with it well
maybe the uh season finale is going to
be a surprise 11th episode
well if it's a double episode I'll I'll
be less angry about the musical I have
to admit
um
you said you're nearly in tears though
why was it that I was just happy well
one I was tired
um I'm running on about three hours of
sleep Conor I don't know if he told you
but he won 900 on the slots last night
um
uh we're meeting all these Amazing Star
Trek people who are incredible
um who are fans of the show and just
fans of Star Trek and uh having such a
good time that it's hard to go to sleep
at the end of the night
yeah I I have you gotta be buzzing yeah
I've just I can't wait to it's just oh
yeah Bruce Bruce Lauren is right there
that's right Houston so is Anthony
Anthony rap yeah no way can you see the
names
oh yeah
no right yeah
Tony Newsome is right here nah Bonnie
Gordon is right here Gary Graham is
right here everyone is right here it's
really fun
no like somebody said Jeffrey Coombs was
saying I joked how would you know right
here how would you know how would you
know Jeffrey Coombs yeah Jeffrey Jeffrey
is playing all of the uh people
attending the convention oh yeah they're
just I I would just have a running joke
every time I announced anybody if I was
joking I would just walk on
that's funny it is Benjamin Cisco and I
would just walk on
um but
I mean
for me I thought the songs were okay in
strange new worlds I Thought I Loved
nurse chapel song um I'm ready I thought
yeah I really loved uh uh
Lance song
about loving Kirk about uh sharing her
emotions
yeah I thought that was your feelings
from the answer that it looked like they
were going to end up in bed together but
it was just uh
dream
um but for me though science sci-fi
should be this could have an element of
science to it
does it matter to you in the slightest
that the reasoning behind the singing
was utter nonsense
sorry somebody in the chat said I know
that person back there that's Ange
uh what was your question I'm sorry
um so it's just as a Sci-Fi fan I think
science fiction should have set of rules
but I think it should be you know have
some science to it does it matter the
reason why they started singing
they really did try to have like a
scientific explanation but it was
nonsense does that matter
oh I mean all science in uh sci-fi is
nonsense because it's all
magic right uh we try very hard to come
up with plausible uh explanations for
the technological leap but at the end of
the day uh we need this to work for our
plot so
yeah I think that's just that's
something you have to accept If You're a
Star Trek fan you know people will say
warp drive is implausible people will
say Subspace communication period isn't
plausible uh all of the things that they
do in Star Trek is completely improbable
technologically it's it's no different
than magic uh so uh I don't know that
that's an argument
that I accept from you
well I think all so a lot in Enterprise
a lot in Star Trek Through the Ages even
back to T and zero they would take a nub
of something that scientifically was a
theory or something that made sense
apparently built a story around it well
what happened in this episode uh it was
what
um the a time a Subspace fold yeah right
and uh they hit it with the some
frequency and it resonated yeah and made
everyone sing
um
I mean it's it's a musical episode of
Star Trek I don't know that the science
needs like we don't need a panel of the
most Brilliant Minds on Earth to tell us
that the science behind it is
Christine I think it was just fun to see
a musical episode and it was nice I
think that they
you know tried to explain it instead of
just letting it be a musical yeah maybe
maybe I I my opinion might change on
that but I'd have just done psychic
alien that lives inside the Subspace
fold was trying to communicate with the
crew and that's how they tried to
communicate there you go the most Star
Trek way to do it but they didn't they
tried to create like a Subspace improper
ballot of improbability and probability
sphere or something yeah wave it maybe
that did maybe chuckle I have to admit
straight face I was just like that's
stupid you're actually right I think uh
an alien in the fold uh who received the
musical the music from Uhura and Spock
and then
trying to communicate with them uh
making them
communicate only in musicals in
emotionally vulnerable moments there's
actually probably a better
because then I like that idea they'd
have to all be sidekick for it to work
anyway because obviously they all start
dancing synchron so they would have to
be
there'd have to be some sort of psychic
thing going on for it to work and and
it's just actually interesting but I I
was how's that going please be an alien
please be psychicating please be psychic
gaming
um
the only bit of the episode that made me
physically angry was the Klingons boy
band moment oh my God I loved it I
stopped it I literally stood up I
rewound it and I watched that moment
again because
uh that was some that was solid gold and
the the uniforms they were wearing
as soon as I saw him earlier on in the
episode I was like yeah they're gonna do
some something silly with that Klingon
um I love that it was the actor that
played the chief engineer from the first
season whose name has just come out but
um I I I've read Because I did a video
immediately after doing this and I have
to admit I said I'm I'm I don't like it
I love it I adored it it was the best
startup episode
this was a step too far for me
um oh that's too bad tell you what the
comments though have been so this was a
proper you don't really have Marmite in
your country in America because
Bruce harack is literally right here
he's right there
I'll tell you again it's the comments
it's such a divisive episode I mean new
track is divisive I think it's fair too
we can track his you know people some
people yeah I mean a huge part of the
community uh precedes new tracks so that
kind of I think is just that goes hand
in hand I think we talk about this a lot
on our show people tend to think that
the Star Trek that was their Gateway
Trek is the only real trick and
everything else is silly or old or new
or
so I don't know
in Psychology so I've I've come from a
psychology background that's my when I
went to UNI and did something and they
call it sort of the Golden Age thinking
and um it's everyone has that those
bands that they loved like 16 to 25
that's when music and everything after
that music died and I do wonder if
there's an element of that with Star
Trek and goes well no I that my golden
age of Star Trek was yeah and everything
else is just stupid
um I think I think that's I think that's
a real thing and I actually think the
way you put it is way better than
because I've tried to explain this a lot
that this is my working Theory and you
calling it The Golden Age conundrum I
think I'm gonna I'm gonna steal that
from you that's that's a good
explanation it's the same in music
honestly everyone thinks that like say
music died when they were about 25 years
old and it didn't it just changed
um but but yeah
um
okay put it this way then do you think
this musical episode or would you agree
with me this musical episode would have
been better as a Christmas special or a
bonus just not as the ninth episode of
this season
uh I think uh a a musical Christmas
special would have been amazing I hope
they have one uh answering it because
obviously the rules went straight out of
the window so Santa Claus could have
come in done a little bit of a dance it
would have been nice
um with the elves obviously
um I'm being facetious
um or even the bonus 11th episode
um like I said I suspect uh
I have a suspicion that there's
something in store for us with the c
series season finale uh
and uh it just didn't seem it seemed
they probably had a big narrative
you know about face that is probably
more important than you know a musical
episode I think by definition would have
to be basically a throwaway
like it you know you're never going to
want to draw on that more than just like
an inside joke you know some future show
will reference that time the Enterprise
made everyone in the Galaxy start
living in a musical yeah uh it's Mega
Dune schmidoon is that what it's called
schmidoon
uh that was great that was fun
um
I think that uh it should have been
maybe not a Christmas special but you
know I kind of like that it uh was uh
like uh
we got a week away from some of the
dramatic storytelling you know sometimes
it gets a little heavy with all the
drama it's nice to have a throw in have
you got that much drama in this season
really sure I mean Spock and his uh wife
their relationship is
Dead Or Not Dead his relationship with
uh nurse Chapel uh Pike uh is struggling
with hmm you know being a
interesting Captain
um it's his Chef skill so he's
struggling with he can't quite get that
quotient
um I've heard you talk about it I
actually like that he's a chef it's fun
for me because I'm a chef but there's
been a lot of cookies I like the other
aspect to his thing but it's every week
he's sort of like he's cooking something
else that's uh
it's a lot but um it makes me hungry
every time I watch Star Trek now I'm
like
I need to I need to go get something to
eat afterwards which is fun but uh
I just think that I just wonder whether
it's one
there's not enough Star Trek in the
season
you know I mean it's like we have the
Spock becoming a human being comedy
episode the crossover episode and the
musical that's three out of ten episodes
that are like risky fun silly episodes
I'm wondering maybe into one too many
maybe a little bit more Star Trek
um
I don't know I see what you're saying uh
but I think
in the glut of Trek that has come
recently it's all been so dramatic that
I don't mind that the that we've had
three episodes out of the last nine that
are um
light-hearted and fun
uh I will I will always I will always
say you know we should maintain that
balance you know I think the Next
Generation I think the original series I
think uh
even Deep Space Nine and and uh
less Voyager but Enterprise found a
balanced uh the drama was always there
the
um
the drama's always there but they were
still always able to throw a joke in or
like wink at it and have fun and we
don't see that much since Discovery so
it was nice to just Revel in it
I would argue yeah that Discovery was so
serious and so dramatic and heavy-handed
yeah
there's something a bit different a big
heavy storylines as well that you know
and they've been no letter pretty there
was no
light-hearted type or very little it's
nice to have something going the other
way okay
I think I won that one I think that's
one meal to me I think
[Laughter]
people keep score we'll keep score
Canon doesn't matter in new Trek
sticking to the rules is boring anyway
how much does Canon matter when you're
talking about yeah
oh heavens I think the big cannon
manners uh so we were just having a
conversation here about
um well there's one of the panels here
is about the difference between
headcanon uh the the Canon that fans
kind of run with uh versus what we
actually see and
um
I don't have a problem what do they call
it retconning
yeah uh that doesn't bother me as long
as it's not for a dumb reason
[Music]
uh I have no problem accepting that
uh
it's been 60 years since this thing
started and
there's going to be some red just
because everything has changed Society
has changed culture has changed
technology has changed
um
I think even in the in the in the
narrative part the uh telling the
stories the people who make Star Trek
are learning what works and what doesn't
what what makes things easier and what
makes things more difficult and try to
make that adjustment so that
storytelling
is more dramatic more interesting
um and not a throwaway so I don't mind
these requons I think
I think they're probably good
so they're even sort of making little
jokes about it now yeah and they're
having fun yeah I just love it when
trekkies when whenever they um
or something gets a bit confusing
um trekkies will think of an excuse to
make quite make sense
particularly from new track
put him
I wonder if we I I think I'm quite
negative towards nutrition
but I have to try to drag myself back
and remember that TNG used to break
Canon all the time
Star Trek used to do the original series
used to and that was when it was fresh
and new they used to put your own toes
occasionally oh they would break their
own cannon in the same episode in the
original series
like we just forgot uh
so maybe we shouldn't worry about it too
much but when we do things like the
technical manuals and things like this
and they really try to put detail behind
the track
and then
well
I will say that all of those because you
know I'm obsessed with the technical
manuals and the additional materials
that are available for Star Trek band
Star Trek encyclopedias things like that
uh but they're not actually created by
the people who make and write Star Trek
they're made by the original technical
manual was it was written by Rick Berman
wasn't it I think it was written by
Micah Cuda and Rick Roman shirt yeah but
that was um just for the Enterprise d
right yeah yeah the Enterprise dude yeah
yeah and there's not much Cannon to
break there
no I mean I like the the moment that
manual came out I'm like when is the
saucer gonna crash land on a planet
and we got it yeah it was definitely
gonna happen yeah as soon as they
decided that sorcer could separate we
all yeah we all know
it was crazy before that special effect
it was definitely gonna okay
um
is there a lion though is there is there
a line that they just can't cross or do
you think it's a story
dictates it then it's okay I think it's
a moving line I think it's a gray area I
don't think it's a hard you know you
know white line on the on the road it's
um
I think if it's not too egregious
uh and also like I said we change uh
society's so different now than it was
20 years ago than it was 60 years ago uh
we we generically speaking we as a
population as a people understand
the Techno Babble significantly better
than back in the day
um so it's getting harder to make that
you know
to make it sound legit you know it's
harder to impress people we're more
educated we can Google it
things like does that make sense so like
my my Star Trek
say hi to Erica hey Erica how are you he
says Hi how are you oh
it's Jay hey Jay
I can't hear you
no no problem I do sign language but not
very well I do sign language not very
well
maybe I can steal his earphones at the
end
please don't
say Erica comes on and everyone gets
much more happy
for the next 15-20 minutes or whatever
um but yeah I just think um I think
there is a there is a line I think there
are rules and I think
new track has been a bit fast and loose
with some of them but I agree with that
I'm worrying about just so much
oh I think that's great for you
for your mental health for your life for
your family
I mean I really like these conversations
that you and I have but it's it's
probably better if you just enjoy it
I remember coming we're going to talk
about the JJ Abrams Star Treks in a
minute but I remember coming out of
there just going no it's not this and if
that make the Enterprise watercolored
and they're getting really angry yeah
it's a fun film I watched it again last
night it's a fun film
uh forgive me a second I'm noticing that
we're getting some uh super Chats on our
YouTube page uh gavatron says my problem
with new track is that it seems the
writers are trying to fix the work of
former writers rather than honor it the
exception being card season three
um yeah kind of
I don't know that they're trying to fix
the old work so much as they're trying
to make their own work
uh I would say uh I'm sorry gavatron
that we can't
pipe you in because that would be a fun
thing to talk about
uh John I was 16 years old when Star
Trek the Original Series came on the air
and I have uh not believe that it was
the only great check each Trek has its
own value of the franchise and I've
enjoyed each one of them over the years
and I agree with you John 100
uh each each show has its proud
yeah 100
um
just a second
I think uh I'm not oh there you go
another black hat
um yeah I think we should get a bit of
Star Trek storyline Crossover with some
professional wrestling
that's amazing
in this in strange new worlds
um that would be amazing a Goran
wrestler yeah well we've already seen it
a little bit
um yeah I was gonna say that's how they
came into being
in fact the guy the guy who played that
born is right here
on the other side of this yeah just run
over on Karate shopping I'm going to you
know no I'm gonna I'm gonna shoot him
with uh a chemical bath of compounds and
components that I find on here in Vegas
um Sean Sullivan put it super chat on
but I didn't see it I'm sorry Sean that
was my fault I wasn't it's not the
ignore them I was so involved in the
chat I wasn't looking in the comments I
apologize and we'll keep an eye open for
any more that pop up there I will watch
for them
um so where were we where were we where
were we um so yeah I I I'm I'm deciding
that Canon there's gotta be fluid as
well and it's just if they've got a good
story then they shouldn't have a Canon
yeah block it if a good story is a good
story at the end of the day I've met
some amazing people at this convention
who um you know like they're members of
their own Starfleet organization they
have you know rules and they're all over
the world and there's you know hundreds
or thousands of them
um it's if you want to be that hardcore
about your Canon and uh role play in
that way there's there's a space for you
to do it and there's people who really
want to do that with you
um but as far as watching an episode of
Star Trek I kind of like it to be a
little gray fluid
I think it's it's nice that people do
get passionate about it though because
it means because we love it at the end
of the day I wouldn't if I didn't love
Star Trek I wouldn't give a flying crap
that they get the color of something
wrong or you know it's because I love it
that I care
um and some people care a little bit too
much and they scare even me
um but at the end of the day
because we love it so
you know I'm on a lot of groups and
things and people keep saying like ah
don't leave your negative comments at
home and it goes oh well no these are
people that love Star Trek
so everyone's opinion matters let's talk
about it you know it's like yes
I love the talking about it part yeah
um so anyway the next thing was prequels
don't add to the richness of Star Trek
they just confuse things
um
I I hate prequels Mark I hate that yes
um I I really really hate them
when they're good they're amazing
because they add a lot to the storyline
and we can learn so much more about
characters
but they're almost never good
and even strange new worlds
the problem I have with strange new
worlds is we know where it ends we know
where it's going in just a couple of
years so they're having to create stuff
like a goal that are all of a sudden
these
powerful enemy with brilliant starships
and things
that's never been mentioned before Star
Trek ever on Globe kind of planets you
know that was Elizabeth
is adding anything to those characters I
think it's actually taken away
well okay so there's something to be
said about the goran's example
specifically because the Gorn
was such I mean talk about the crossover
between Star Trek and wrestling like it
was such a weird moment in time I think
there aren't very many people on the
planet Star Trek then or not who
wouldn't recognize the image of Kirk you
know squaring off against that giant
goofy looking rubber Gorn
um uh so that is a little difficult to
do anything with because it's such an
iconic moment in not just in Star Trek
but in storytelling you know the
adventure of story of narrative
storytelling in human history that is a
a fundamental moment
um
uh I I do enjoy that they've been
laying in the Gorn as like this vicious
uh not well understood
predatory species
um
[Music]
I think less is better
uh I think they may I think what I have
a suspicion and correct me if I'm wrong
I think that you react negatively to
Born specifically so much because they
probably showed too much of the Gorn
and they didn't let it remain a mystery
they've had some very cool sort of
almost horror episodes with them though
that they worked I mean like I said they
Flex I love them yeah I love those
episodes they're really good
um I just wonder if it would have been
better if they'd have focused I mean we
have a load of comments in here saying
focus more on the tholians which is an
enemy that we know we're technologically
advanced technology yeah or more so
um but they went with the go on that
maybe they went with the ball because we
don't know them but now all of a sudden
they're sort of like a federation
threatening
species so it's going to be interesting
to see how did that includes because
obviously we didn't we don't see them
all later so they're going to get wiped
out are they gonna I don't know
go ahead sorry it's very loud here no no
we weren't going to make friends of them
at the end of the day so it's just going
to see how they conclude that that
doesn't sort of effect
the later that they just don't get
mentioned again basically
I suppose
um I would also say just sort of
generically speaking um
I don't I personally don't mind prequels
I think it's fun to go and uh flesh out
uh universes that have already been
built
um yeah and I would argue that strange
new worlds is not a prequel
because Enterprise made everything not a
prequel
uh any any real prequel would have to be
before Enterprise now
that is a good point I I feel that's are
you a lawyer in a premium
technicality but I know a lot of lawyers
it was a good thing I like it
um I just wonder for me exchange new
worlds was um Captain poke aboard the
Endeavor with his friends it would have
made for a maybe a better series because
it wouldn't have been the Enterprise
they seem to be obsessed with everything
being the Enterprise
and I just want to well uh I I hear what
you're saying and I kind of agree with
that and and
um it's actually recently that I formed
a better opinion about that Connor and
Dominic talk a lot about you know what
the show what the show they were in was
about
and Connor said something that really
sort of rattled something loose in my
mind he said the show's not about
blah blah blah it's about the ship the
ship is the star of the show
uh and it like so much of my life
finally made sense when he said
I think there's a truth to that I think
that um there's this unhealthy obsession
with the Enterprise specifically
uh in the hallways of the powers that be
that make these shows
um that know that the ship is the star
and
um in an effort to keep the audience
getting What It Wants they're just
giving us more Enterprises
um
oh we're on like seven cerix yeah
so how many sarics are we on how many
actors have played Sarah like seven
yeah like seven
um I I just I just wonder it's a big
unit
I I have this argument there's only so
many stories
before you go you know what there's
other places go somewhere else there's
like there's a lot of battles happening
let's move on we're on our third curve
I'd like to see different characters
you like to see a different oh so you're
saying they should go Voyager
they should take a page from Voyager and
Deep Space Nine I want to do the
adventures of the USA or that you know
anything and just like let's see some
new adventures in a new thing and then
but I think it's easy for the writers
because they're not tied down by what's
already been on screen they can do what
was what was the name of the ship in
Alien
oh the one with loads and loads of guns
no in Alien the uh the first alien movie
the one that Sigourney Weaver blew up
oh I don't know
oh yeah I'm going to Google
dance quickly what was this what is the
name of the ship that Sigourney Weaver
blew up in Alien
foreign
[Music]
thank you I kept wanting to say the
Botany Bay but I knew that that was
Khan's uh
Nostromo thank you yeah oh Alan got in
there quick link within astronomer yeah
um
Sean thank you Sean
very good
um yeah I just wish they'd done that but
but that that gets us on to the next
next little thing Star Trek Enterprise
would have been better
if it had focused I know you've got a
lot going on around sorry and Patrick
Enterprise would have been better
focused more on the formation of the
Federation and wasn't called Enterprise
Kirk's Enterprise was the first
Enterprise
now I know they got around that with
technicality
and as a lawyer you'll probably go yes
but it was an NX plan it doesn't count
correct that is exactly what I was about
to say it was an experimental class of
ship and um and they even got away with
that in the very last episode because
they decommissioned it literally the day
the Federation became the Federation so
they even knew
they were like Federation decommissioner
immediately
um but it really could have been called
anything why did it have to be the
Enterprise
I think that that goes back to what we
were just talking about I think that the
you know that you know Rick Berman knew
uh that the ship is the star and you
know from the original series and into
the movies we had gone through seven
seasons of The Next Generation seven
seasons of these first name seven
seasons of voyagers so that's what 600
episodes or more of Television
um over a period of how you know
15 16 years
so to go back to the Enterprise I think
was a bit of you know Nostalgia churning
and and doing uh Star Trek Enterprise as
a prequel I think was Nostalgia churning
anyway
um
I uh
I don't know I never had a problem with
it
I like the Enterprise
I just called it something else but I
love the show
um I thought they got the technology but
hang on and I love that the feel of the
show was absolutely bang on
um I thought they cast it brilliantly
except for that Connor Connor idiot
other than that right here now the
casting was brilliant honestly Tripp was
Britain malcol brilliant obviously all
these great characters they cast it
beautifully
um it was beautiful to watch it was
thick I just think this was too much on
that time travel stuff
um
Sean Sullivan middle name Cisco Kirk or
O'Brien
uh Tiberius is Kurtz uh miles Edward
O'Brien uh Cisco
I don't I don't know
what's uh Cisco's middle name
she doesn't know either the girl who won
our live event trivia contest is
standing here and she doesn't know it
either
you out Google there you go
uh I want to uh shout out I got a
message from Sean
uh who's watching our show right now uh
their their Vineyard uh Alamitos uh just
became the number one new winery
experience in the United States of
America and they are a sponsor of our
show they're going to be they provided
us uh bottles of their wine we give
bottles
of alcohol to our guests so we've got a
lot of uh Alamitos wine to hand out
we're really excited about it
um
I'm also open to being sponsored by any
winery in the UK
um there's one in your toxicity that's
up the road if you'd like to my email
address is on the page
um that would be very nice thank you
um yeah so
do you think there's any way they could
have saved Enterprise to get past Four
Seasons what could they've done
differently in the last season Maybe
uh I don't think uh it had anything to
do with the show they were making and it
had everything to do with the the
infrastructure of Television around the
way things were changing in the
television business landscape when
um Enterprise was out uh if the in
numbers that Enterprise had on UPN if
that was now
they would have 20 Seasons so uh
Super Bowl numbers I think it's fun
it has to do with um
you know Paramount trying to spin off
its own network at a time where maybe
that was a little too little too late
uh no one understood DVRs no one wanted
to understand DVRs because it meant that
the known uh funding apparatus threat of
uh
providing uh
Anthony Montgomery and Ciroc Lofton are
dancing on the table oh and Jeffrey
Combs just walked up
yeah
I can share I can share them spin around
and find out
[Laughter]
no way
next year
you guys can't see it it's in person
it's a lot more obvious what's happening
on the camera it just looks like a bunch
of people in a shopping mall it's and
I'm just going to point out that it's um
10 to 11 in the morning there and
they're already dancing on the tables
yes
um
uh Carey you're welcome
for doing a double live stream we
appreciate you
yeah Kerry's an amazing CC supporter
Town absolutely we love Kerry
um I just think I don't think there's
anything wrong I love that show um I
know people knowing about the it's been
a long road I actually really like to
start
we led a uh a sing-along of that last
night we ended the karaoke with that
yeah it's been a long road I loved it um
and like I said the casting was perfect
and I the only thing I'd have liked to
have seen was the upgrades to the
Enterprise you know I'd like to have
seen the the reef and if we'd got that I
think that would have been brilliant one
less gripe Enterprise had the best
explanation for the change
the retcon really dishonest work of the
previous writers
the Klingons they're merging the
Klingons together the one thing they're
they're fixing that again yeah they
should they shouldn't fix it they should
just ignore it uh you know I understand
I've had this conversation especially
specifically about the Klingons and
Discovery
um I have no problem with a filmmaker
coming in new to the franchise saying uh
the Klingons are vicious War Monsters
they were built for you know conquering
other worlds uh let's make them big and
scary and and you know completely alien
and uh I actually I liked it in fact uh
what's her face is right here the play
on Chancellor from Discovery
America is it Mary I see they're playing
on chances
yes
oh Tipo right there very Cheapo she's
right there
so I'm not going to talk too much about
her version of Klingon while she's right
there
but I actually I like it and I I don't
think that we need an explanation for
why they look
old school again I think
it's it's become a Klingon thing they
just change
first they look like bronze uh actors
from the 60s then they look like you
know
Runners and then they just had a bunch
of Romulan
yeah and then they look like Wharf for a
long time and then they look horrible
monstery and then they look like uh
updated warps yeah it it fit the tone
for What discovery was going for we'll
go with that and um but but yeah no it
was it was yeah
I think we just need to leave discuss
the first student Discovery to it I want
to say something uh about uh gavatron's
comment though I and I appreciate what
he's saying here uh and some of the
other comments has made
um but I don't know that and maybe he's
just making a joke saying dishonors
because it's a Klingon thing
um I don't know that um you know if I
were to be writing an episode of Star
Trek if I if I did something that
changed or adjusted or explained or
fleshed out something that had already
been established I don't know that I'm
dishonoring another writer's work uh I I
you know I
yeah
oh no we might have lost mark
I suppose he's in Las Vegas
and the wife I might have uh might not
be amazing where he is and sat in a
hotel
ah dang it well we'll give Mark a couple
of seconds to see if he comes back with
hope and so we've got one last little
comment to make about the future of Star
Trek
um
while we got here please go and check
the description if you're a site tracker
please go and subscribe to the
shuttlepod show if you're a shuttle pod
show fan please come over and subscribe
to the Sidetrack Channel we have videos
almost every day talking about Sidetrack
and Stargate and everything else
um maybe not all the killing is affected
by the virus both type battle for power
and thanks
I think there's a you could always just
argue with the Klingons to be honest
they're just from different parts of
Kronos
you know you get different we we look
different in this part of the world so
why couldn't you know the Klingons look
different just because they're from
different parts of Kronos I don't know
also it's an Empire their empire could
be vast it could be a hundred different
worlds that you know they are coming and
out of so again you could have different
types of Klingon so I don't think the
different types of
um Klingons is a problem from dumpster
to the Grave all we needed to explain
the Klingons was the line from Deep
Space Nine of wolf says we do not
discuss it with Outsiders and as Brian
says why the Klingons always look
different it's as simple as that you
could have just kept it that but I do
think strange new worlds in particular
new Trek now they're trying to fix it
and I mentioned earlier that in strange
new Wills have started to sort of poke
fun and have a laugh about the things
that they've got wrong and the changes
they've made
but you get new writers coming in and
you want to then put your stamp on
things or you want to tell a story a
slightly different way over the
different tone and you're going to
change the way things look they wanted
very much for the tone of that to be
more of a horror and um
they changed the way they look for that
sorry about that not a problem you're in
Vegas what happened to Vegas days in
Vegas so what happened
it was simply it was too real to show it
was and and yeah I don't yeah and let's
just leave it we've got one more little
statement before and then we'll let you
go to enjoy Vegas but not too much
today's gonna be today's gonna be a nap
day
is it really okay
right so we are in a golden age of Star
Trek or are we
yeah so what do you think is it
I think we are in a golden age of Star
Trek there's never been more Star Trek
going on at once I mean uh lower decks
is some of the best television I have
ever seen and the fact that the whole
thing is a uh inside joke for
People Like Us Star Trek fans it's so
awesome you know
Prodigy got canceled just as I was
getting into it that's really sad but
you know we had Prodigy Laura Dex Picard
and strange new worlds and Discovery all
going on at the same time that's
outpaces everything else preceding it so
um
I do think we're in a golden age of Star
Trek uh
and I I embrace that it's different than
the Star Trek I grew up on
uh you know if you want to watch serious
Star Trek you watch Discovery if you
want to watch musical Star Trek you
watch strange new worlds
and if you want to if you want to be a
big giant inside joke about how big of a
Star Trek nerd you are like me then you
watch lower decks it's great
and if you want to watch uh
I was going to say something negative
about Picard but I'm not gonna because I
love the card
I think you can you can dislike the
first two seasons I was gonna I was
gonna make a joke about the first two
seasons of good card uh but I decided
not to God even I will get angry at you
if you were negative about the third
season of Picard
um quantity is not quality that's that's
correct regulus zero zero zero uh
uh
but I I do I would argue that a lot of
the new Trek is quality it's the best if
you like special effects and everyone
says they're into great special effects
it's astonishing the what what it looks
like now uh you know the discovery
brought that in like oh my God finally a
TV show that looks like a movie
you know it was amazing battle of the
binary Stars those those two episodes of
discovery that that launched Discovery
it was so good a Klingon yellow or the
Volcan hello I just looked at the the
open sequence where Michelle Young and
the captain Oh his name's gonna met
uh Captain uh green remember green what
that's the captain in Discovery remember
green
um
it's the same as empress
oh man
who's the star of discovery
um
[Music]
I love All Star Trek you know there's a
lot of people in the comments on our
page and I don't know about your page
but um uh you know if Star Trek's if a
certain show isn't for you it's not for
you that's fine uh but I I really
believe I came into this conversation I
wanted to have a t-shirt that said
hashtag all Trek is good trick and we we
talk about it a lot like if it's not
your Trek I can promise you
if being here is perfect proof that if
it's not your trick it's somebody's
trick and if you don't like it you don't
like it why on uh someone else who
is inspired by it or feels like uh
they're seen because they're being
represented in new Trek it's uh I love
it I love it so much I love Star Trek
like I was so excited when you when you
said you wanted to have this
conversation I got so excited I was like
oh my God
people are quite nasty comments about my
last video they're saying because I
don't like the musical episode but I'm
like well I was I raved about October
episode and I know one of my friends who
is a subscriber said he hates the
crossover episode but he looks the
musical episode
this isn't that the point that's that's
that's okay but the thing is what you
want to do do I want a generic TV show
that everybody is like okay with or do
you want a TV show that does take risks
and does go a bit
and they're going to get it wrong
sometimes but they take risks do
something a bit crazy
um every time yeah well that's that's
the point of Star Trek for me then I
want them to take this yes I didn't want
to watch this episode
we'll do it
but I love a show that's brave enough to
do that
and to do something that I'm not gonna
like
because then they do a crossover episode
and I've watched it three times
just noticed that uh we have a side
track shuttlepod crossover going on
right now
we do indeed
um and I'm gonna do the Riker maneuver
in a minute and uh just cotton leg over
the chair and it'll I've got a bad back
so it'll end up with me on the floor but
um but it got it at least once
oh yeah just biker
um thank you so so much
um do you want to say hi to Erica why
not let's say hello to Erica because say
hello to Erica
say hi
hello
how are you good how are you how are you
enjoying Vegas is
mildly behaved
I'd like to ask about Connie for a
minute because I'm hoping they're not so
um
I'm hoping um Conor and Dominic aren't
behaving no they're they're certainly
not
good so what are you up to now for the
rest of the day over in Las Vegas
uh so I believe we have a little lunch
with Muhammad Noor gonna catch up with
him are you familiar with him yes a
little bit yeah yeah and then
um I'm thinking about maybe getting some
uh Vulcan ears put on by John who's
right next to us
we'll see maybe today maybe tomorrow huh
John John Paladin so check him out
um and uh she's got a couple outfits for
me that I might be wearing so that's
exciting
do a little cosplay and then I don't
know that's it that's it for today just
hanging out at the booth because I
wasn't here yesterday I personally
wasn't at the booth yesterday so I'm
excited to just chat with people
no that's amazing I said to immerse
yourself in something like that I just
I'm so jealous
you're in Britain where it's yes just
about raining
um we haven't had a summer this year she
started to rain all summer oh shucks I
know but next year I will be in Vegas
have you been here before I've been to
Vegas twice but not to a convention
I'm the only nerd in my Throne group so
they wouldn't let me okay
A little YouTube channel I've made new
friends so I've got people to go with so
um San Diego Comic-Con and then Star
Trek Las Vegas
next year
I'm gonna say hi to puka hair as a thank
you
um
before you before we say goodbye who's
next on this channel
who's next on the show yeah like who's
our next who's our next guest yeah
that's a fantastic question well are we
still going to try to snatch it snatch a
guest for this weekend yes we're gonna
try to have a surprise guest this
weekend so I can't tell you
uh is that here's me asking a question
you couldn't answer but
um somebody from the uh from the
convention is going to get grabbed and
thrown into a room are they yeah we're
gonna kidnap them excellent good good
well thank you so so much Erica and Mark
whatever responded off to with a drink I
should imagine
um it's been brilliant can you thank
Connor and um and our Dominic first as
well and I certainly will amazing to see
life from Star Trek that's Vegas
I hope to speak with you again soon
thank you thank you okay bye-bye
hello
she is absolutely Lovely Isn't She
Lovely isn't She the most lovely person
yeah I got all shy talking to a pretty
lady
so so much for um well getting us into
Star Trek Live for one and a lot of
people don't get to see this so we get
to actually see what these conventions
are like
um well yeah I I like I really like that
you invited me to have this conversation
and I thought maybe we could make it a
regular thing as our show starts to uh
go to conventions and and all that it
would be nice to pull some people aside
and let them say hi to you and your fans
and uh this has been real great you're
you're really good at um
you're British so you're really good at
having a conversation
I appreciate it thank you so much for
saying that I really appreciate it
this is great
yeah anyway so um everybody look we've
had over 250 people most of the video so
thank you everyone's gotten the comments
as well contributions to Sidetrack and
thank you so much for those
we'll see you next time
thank you Jay Potter thank you thank you
and thank you Jay so much thank you
you're very very welcome I can't wait
till next time